I'm joined today by dr. Jeff Szymanski
who's currently the executive director
of the international OCD foundation jeff
was previously the director of
psychological services at McLean
Hospitals OCD Institute he's also author
of the book the perfectionists handbook
and serves as a Clinical Instructor in
psychology at Harvard Medical School so
Jeff let's start sort of at the top when
we talk about OCD obsessive compulsive
disorder there's a lot of sort of
laypersons terms that are thrown around
about what that is and what the symptoms
are but what are we talking about when
we talk about OCD yeah so in the way
that you just said the best place to
start is to define some of those terms
because the way people use for example
obsession and late conversation is
different than how you sit in in
psychology and psychiatry so obsessive
in general conversation means I'm
obsessed with my favorite baseball team
I'm obsessed with the color purple
meaning I really like something that's
how we use it when we use the word
compulsive in everyday language we're
talking about people that are neat
people that are wanted people that are
very detail-oriented
people that are perfectionistic right so
the problem with those two terms in lay
language having the same words in the
title of OCD is that everyone gets them
confused right so they say oh I'm a
little OCD because I'm obsessed with
having my sock drawer compulsively
arranged and so what happens for people
with OCD is they hear that they're like
oh you just don't really understand or
get my experience because in the context
of obsessive compulsive disorder
obsession means unwanted intrusive
thoughts and images things I don't want
to be thinking about things I don't want
to be seeing in my mind and they create
a lot of unwanted feelings primarily
anxiety but also guilt disgust other
kinds of feelings that a person with OCD
doesn't want to have so these these
obsessions actually turn up in a lot of
frequency and a lot of intensity and so
as the anxiety increases and the
unwanted feelings the unwanted thoughts
increase the person feels compelled to
engage in compulsive behavior now the
compulsive behaviors are repeated
behaviors you're doing internally so it
could be counting or praying or saying a
good word over and over again in order
to keep yourself safe but more could be
external behavior so a lot of people
have seen the cleaning and and and hand
washing etc but there's a lot of
different kinds of compulsions that
could range from having to do things in
certain number of times or also just
kind of avoiding certain situations that
would evoke the obsessions in the
anxiety so what so the difference
between someone being obsessed with
their baseball team and someone having
OCD is that someone with OCD actually is
suffering on a day-to-day basis and the
anxiety in the obsessions and the
compulsive behavior are time consuming
and they're getting in the way of
day-to-day activities so people are
showing up late to work or they can't
work they can't get their schoolwork
done they're not being able to see
family members or friends that they'd
like be able to be able to see so again
the D and OC d stands for disorder
meaning that the person's day-to-day
functioning is is significantly impaired
how prevalent is OCD in in the sense
that you're describing it in American
society world I mean do we have probably
the world is tough because there's
there's so many countries where we just
really wouldn't have data but maybe in
the u.s. so in the u.s. this has been
shown several times that at any given
point about 1% of the adult population
has OCD and which translates into about
two to three million adults right now
would qualify for an OC diagnosis
another half million to a million kids
would also qualify for an OCD diagnosis
in fact we do have a number of studies
worldwide and that same prevalence of
OCD stays consistent across country that
it's about 1% of the population now
that's interesting where you say it's
consistent across countries because one
of the things I wanted to discuss was
whether OCD is a sort of modern West
condition in the sense that if we were
to go back a hundred thousand years or
something like that in human history do
we know anything about the prevalence of
OCD or something like it or is it really
something that has been sort of created
or a result of modern westernization so
we know from neuroimaging studies
actually that there are some brain
abnormalities for people that have OCD
we know from genetics research that
about one in four kids that have a
parent with OCD will have OCD so there's
a genetic transmission there's a
neurobiological component to this the
way that people have talked about OCD
and other mental illness um historically
is looking at autobiographies that
people wrote or biographies where people
had written about him Vincent van Gogh I
think was a example of someone who
likely suffered from bipolar disorder so
the idea that it that it's a a modern
kind of a modern manifestation of
something about our society probably not
so much I think mental illness has been
around for quite a while and you know to
this day what we still hear people say
is I had OCD for many years I just
didn't have a name for it I didn't know
what it was so I think that that was the
case historically is that someone was
behaving in an odd way
I mean reporting being very distressed
and they just didn't have a name for it
you talked about some of the examples of
what our actual OCD symptoms are there
examples of symptoms attributed to OCD
that aren't really OCD symptoms I think
it probably it probably goes in the
other direction where what what the
number of people in our community find
is that they were misdiagnosed with
something else rather than OCD so for
example people some people with OCD will
have violent thoughts and there are
thoughts that they don't want to have it
isn't I had a thought of harming someone
and I think I might do it it's the exact
opposite there they're so concerned that
they had the thought that they now start
policing their mind oh my goodness of
have this thought again this is a
terrible thing I'm a terrible person and
then they start engaging in all this
compulsive behavior to make their mind
not think these thoughts again you're
not a violent person they've never
committed any violence in the past and
so what happens is that they they're
they're compulsive behavior increases
they go and report this to a mental
health professional who may not know
about this form of OCD and they start to
think of them as a potential violent
risk same thing with sexual thoughts
there are some people that have unwanted
sexual thoughts and if they go to their
mental health professional who doesn't
know anything about OCD they might think
oh maybe this person has some sort of
sexual disorder or maybe they're at risk
for harming other people and so we don't
have so much other things get confused
with those idiots that OCD actually gets
under not thought of and misdiagnosed
quite frequently a lot of folks that I
work with would be diagnosed with
psychotic illness like schizophrenia
because sometimes the thoughts can be
the obsessions can be very bizarre but
the person knows that the thoughts are
bizarre and that ends up being one of
the primary differences what constitutes
treatment for OCD can it be treated
effectively is our our pharmaceuticals
the answer is is it something else so
unfortunately the research recent
research is showing it takes somewhere
between 14 to 17 years between onset of
OCD symptoms and actually accessing
effective treatment and the problem one
of the many problems with that is that
there is effective treatment and so
there's a class of medications called
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
more commonly thought of as
antidepressants but they have anti OCD
properties as well and so for many
people with mild to moderate OCD they go
to the psychiatrist or primary care
physician if they've been diagnosed with
OCD and they get on an SSRI that might
actually be the treatment of choice for
them there's lots of reasons for showing
that medicating these medications can be
helpful for OCD however the primary
treatment that we work for
two is called exposure and response
prevention therapy and I liken this to
if you know someone who's afraid of dogs
what's the best way to get someone over
their fear of dogs it's you have to
expose them to being around dogs so it's
basically the same kind of an
oversimplified fashion that's basically
the same idea with OCD is that we
actually have the person think the
purposely think about the obsessions and
put themselves in contact with
situations that would evoke anxiety and
then we ask them to not engage in the
compulsive behavior and so when you
break that link of having anxiety and
then responding to it with compulsive
behavior and you now kind of cut that
off what happens is the person will
continue to experience the anxiety and
what your brain does then it says oh
wait a minute this thing that I
categorized as possibly dangerous maybe
isn't as dangerous as I thought it was
and so then your brain starts to
decrease its anxiety and so we called
this habituation and so you get used to
being in a certain situation and over
time if people use exposure response
prevention therapy they expose
themselves to anxiety and situations
that evoke their obsessions they don't
engage in the response prevention as
they don't engage in the compulsive
behavior what they find is that their
anxiety over time decreases and they can
approach more situations absolutely
fascinating the book is the
perfectionists handbook we've been
speaking with the book's author dr. Jeff
Szymanski who is currently the executive
director of the international OCD
foundation thanks so much for talking to
us about this no problem thank you